jusqu'où iriez-vous pour obtenir vos réponses
je sais que vous promettez tout ce que vous voyez
ce permis est dans mon esprit un ingénieur
qui s'est sacrifié avec nous virus
et il a créé cette horrible créature dans
le projet original c'était lv-426 ce que nous
pensions  nous savions que dans le premier extraterrestre n'est
qu'un petit affluent de ce qui se
passe réellement si nous faisons une suite à cette
préquelle, nous découvrirons qui cette race était
d'un ne sont pas des dieux
Prométhée saura mieux
ces ingénieurs maçons nation
où est-il venu  du paradis
hé reviens à la maison
sans t'arrêter ce ne sera pas la maison pour retourner à de
grandes choses avoir de petits débuts